Okay,
you in five,
four,
three,
two.
Hello everybody and welcome to the
podcast experience,
also known as the correct opinions zone.
You disagree with the opinions here.
Take a.
You might want to think twice because
these are infallible,
highly uninformed and 100 percent
correct all the time.
Couldn't possibly be wrong yet.
This was not an option.
It's not in this cell with me as the
beautiful,
talented and very ballou.
Isla Klein.
Round of applause.
And what else?
CEO and annecy.
Oh,
of course.
Thank you.
To today's sponsor is Capterra,
quip and me undies and for all of our
loyal fans and listeners,
there is a new h,
three h,
three video out on our channel H,
three productions.
So I hope you enjoy that.
Check it out.
Please enjoy it today.
We've got a lot to get to.
I've got a new mic.
How do I sound on the Saturday today
we've got the Shane a jake documentary.
I want to talk a little bit about that.
Bill cosby has started a new sitcom and
which he goes to prison,
which is a really,
really looking forward to that.
It's on NBC,
premieres this a fall at a pm.
Looking forward to bill cosby goes to
prison.
We've also got drake and millie.
Bobby Brown had been raising eyebrows
with their salacious.
I feel like that's over the top
interesting relationship and much,
much more.
Oh,
welcome everybody.
To the age three.
Buck gas myriad's.
Alright,
thanks for coming everyone.
We really,
we got the best.
We got the best stuff here to talk
about.
So from the top,
Shane and jake.
Shane Dawson is the king of Youtube.
Yeah.
These past couple of these were kind of
the king of Youtube for like a past year
or something,
but these whole documentary series have
just been over the,
over the top like um,
can you pull up his channel?
I want to show you the views that he's
got there,
but right now he has just come out with
a Jake Paul documentary called inside
the mind of Jake Paul when he tries to
understand really what's going on with
that guy.
And I'm intrigued.
Let's see.
Let's see here.
I'm looking at look at all of his recent
views.
What does that look?
So low quality,
is that just part of the thing?
16 million.
Fourteen million.
18,
$24 million.
I mean this is just.
This is average stuff.
Yeah.
This is insane.
This is like new level shit.
So anyway,
his new documentary about Jake pauls
out.
Look at this.
I loved this.
Um,
Jake's response to part one was number
two,
trending with two point 2 million views
in two days and Shane's video with 10
million views in one day wasn't on
trending.
I don't remember a damn.
What the hell?
What's the logic?
How do you trend Jake Paul's response
video?
I don't know.
I can,
they just fix the trending page and it's
like it's just not a trending page.
And if it is curated,
why did they keep trending?
Jake Paul,
if there's really no good explanation
for why this would be there and not that
one,
it literally is counter intuitive.
That response isn't what's trending,
it's the topic itself,
it's just,
it's maddening.
But regardless.
So that's mine.
The crunch of it is that he's trying to
see if Jake Paul's a sociopath and I
personally don't think that Jake Paul's
a sociopath.
I mean that's a tall claim,
but then it takes this twist where he's
like,
well maybe he's a brother.
Logan is the sociopath and it's about
him living in the shadow of his brother,
which is a really interesting twist and
I definitely can see that.
I could see that.
Yeah,
I can see that for sure.
So I am looking forward to seeing how
this series unveils.
But there was,
by the way,
I think Logan was blindsided by the
whole thing because jake and his video
was like,
I knew it was about sociopathy and he's
like,
I'm not a sociopath so come make this
documentary about me.
He's like,
he's going to be good pr for me.
Shit.
So Logan I think was blindsided that he
was all the sudden coming under the
magnifying lens and he just tweeted out
this morning,
this I really didn't want to,
but I feel compelled to give my thoughts
on Shane series this far.
And then Shane actually responded a
surprise extended finale.
Which is a shame.
Really.
Don't give a fuck he's ready.
But anyway,
the really intriguing thing for me and I
am,
I am,
I'm intrigued.
You know,
I'm,
I'm glued to the set here affect Shane
has given a lot of youtubers hope,
kind of always channel and just turn the
second round.
Well for a long time he was a guy that
just taste tested fast food.
Yeah.
For so long.
I don't know what he was doing before
that.
Those probably.
He did like sketches and she said,
I don't know.
He's not.
He has two channels.
He's been kind of like,
been around forever and doing all kinds
of different content,
but he was just eating food for a long
time,
but he likes this lugged through it,
found his voice and he really has got
this second wind that's unbelievable.
It's really cool.
I really liked the style of the document
date.
If it's fresh,
it's really well edited.
I Dunno who's editing that.
I'm sure Shane is probably sitting there
a lot with the editor,
but the editing.
Absolutely bananas.
Um,
he wears the same shirt in every video I
don't think.
Well,
I don't know if it's the same shirt,
but either that or he's like doug funny
and he's got like,
you know,
you've ever done,
he dug high net worth doing the same
outfit every day and,
but then there's an episode where he
walks in the closet and he just has like
the same outfit.
He wears the same shirt.
God bless his soul.
Um,
yeah,
no,
but hey.
But there was one moment here that
really broke my heart.
There was a moment in the new episode
that really broke my heart as a fan,
as a call.
I want to say colleague,
but maybe an associate you could say as
someone who's had him here,
a guest on our podcast,
it really broke my heart.
So here it is really going to talk about
this.
I do also remember like Jake Paul was on
it.
See if you notice anything here,
kind of missed the timestamp for
Chrissake.
See if you notice anything here.
Okay.
As he was talking about this,
okay,
listen closely,
my friends.
You're all going to really.
This is really upsetting,
but I do also remember like j Dot Paul
was on a podcast and he was about to hit
10 million subscribers
cast on a podcast.
Damn,
now we're spending Shane,
my art.
Shane,
you break in my heart on what podcast
cast
on a podcast.
Shane,
my family isn't.
My Godfather.
Pressure was on her podcast.
What family?
You come in my house.
You sit across the table from me,
but I get no respect to disrespect.
You come.
I'm a podcast on a podcast,
the podcast where you have a podcast in
my mind.
It sounds like a perfect Italian
godfather.
Impression spot on Shane.
Shane,
you break in.
My house is half Russian shade.
He'll break.
Break up.
My aunt gave.
Paul was honored
on a podcast.
Anyway,
God bless them.
I'm not upset.
I just thought it was funny.
I just thought it was a funny
opportunity to do my well traveled,
well seasoned that Godfather but not one
in the pocket for a while here at the
office.
Yeah,
I'm working on that.
My godfather accent for a long time.
So did you change your mind?
But Jake,
Paul or thing would know,
I never thought I,
I kind of always suspected that jake
deep down isn't a bad guy.
I,
I had that impression when I sat here
with him,
I thought,
you know,
because I had a conversation with him
outside off camera and I was like,
do tell me straight.
We were walking to the bathroom together
and I was like,
and this was during their heyday when
they were really competitive.
I was like telling you how are you guys?
Because it seems really toxic.
And he's.
And he said,
honestly,
it's really bad.
We honestly really hate each other.
He told me that in complete earnestness
off camera and the hallway.
He's like,
it's really bad.
Honestly.
You can tell that the competitive it's
mentalities real well.
Apparently Logan actually really fucked.
Did Jake's ex girlfriend like for real?
And then made like a distrac about it.
But Jack was like,
dude,
like,
act like I know that's like good for
views,
but that actually really hurts my
feelings.
You know,
like these guys are fucking twisted.
But apparently jake actually gets into a
lot of this stuff.
So I'm looking forward to that,
but uh,
if you can help me with that music one
more time.
Shane.
I,
what I bring on,
we talk,
we sit across the tip.
Do I do to deserve this disrespect jazz.
This is getting better shit to
disrespect.
I bring him here.
You sit across the table from me with
that.
We have a good time.
What do I do with it?
Has Given me the crickets.
I should have.
Yeah,
you fucked up.
Moving on.
Bill cosby.
There's a new sitcom coming out on NBC,
which is a really ballsy play out their
part.
Bill cosby goes to prison for sexual
assault.
I was like,
wow,
that's really edgy idea.
Um,
wait.
Hold on.
It's not a sitcom in handcuffs.
After getting over three years in prison
for 2000 for rape.
Wait,
I thought.
Oh Man.
I thought it was just a sitcom.
What?
Welcome to Papa's house.
Aka Prison.
The clink.
Isn't that crazy?
It's the same with handcuffs.
Dude.
It is the weirdest timeline.
Can we just reflect on the fact that 81
year old bill cosby worth $400,
million dollars,
America's most beloved entertainer,
Jello in coke,
sip and bill cosby is going,
not just America.
I was like,
interest
is going to prison at 81 years old for
rape.
Fuck,
that's the weirdest timeline imaginable.
Oh my God.
He was convicted in April of drugging
and sexually assaulting Andre Constand,
who testified that cosby violated her at
is Pennsylvania home in 2004 after she
came to him for career advice shoe.
He was sentenced to three to 10 years
for sexual assault.
He has to register as a sex offender.
He's classified as a sexually violent
Predator online and they need to inform
all their neighbors that have sexually
violent Predator lives in the area
that's a lifetime registration.
Although I don't think his life is going
to be much longer.
80 one in prison.
He's in general population to a lot of
people were like,
oh,
he's going to get preferential
treatment.
Listen to this.
Um,
he's in general population and he's so
famous.
You know what they're doing because when
he talks to his wife and prison,
they have speaker phones and like
everyone around can hear,
oh yeah,
it's all monitored because it's a
fucking prison.
You know what I mean?
They always end.
The move is so everyone can hear you're
near or if you're the police,
if you're working there,
you're listening to what they're talking
about.
And so people are paying.
They want to know everything he's
talking about with his wife.
He saw all these tabloids are our
publishing,
everything he's talking about with his
wife.
They can do that.
Well,
that's how they found out.
But I mean pro,
no,
I'm sure it's probably illegal,
but people are getting paid.
Um,
here,
some of the anecdotes that came out of
those phone conversations,
I'm in a phone call with his wife Cosby
recounted that a hot dog bun was thrown
at his face,
a cosby who was legally blind city fell
down a flight of stairs because he
wasn't being guided and was without his
cane,
which was apparently taken away along
with his shoe laces by correctional
officers over fears that he might harm
himself.
Cosby told his wife,
grabbed the check book and hire anyone
and everyone who could get him out as
soon as possible.
This mother fucker's worth $400,
million bucks.
And that money can not save him.
This article says he said it.
No,
the officials think he'll harm himself.
I mean,
cosby tells wife officials.
Oh,
he,
he told his wife though,
officials think all harm myself because
they took away his cane and his
shoelaces,
as I understand is normal,
but God damn.
Can you imagine you're just like in
prison and you're like,
oh,
it's bill cosby know.
Hey Bill.
Oh,
and here's another great one.
His first meal and prison.
The NYLA pudding.
Yeah,
but the bunny at the.
You put the hot dog,
the face of the podium to the mouth.
Really showing off your impressions to
that is the impression and experience
the age and experience.
But Shit,
you know,
how could he do this?
You put the Putty,
you came here,
I gave you politic and you said a
podcast.
How am I doing over impression?
I'll animate crossovers right there.
Um,
so I think it's so pathetic.
God.
Bill cosby in prison at 81.
So weird people will throw in a hot dog
buns at his face like,
like that's maybe the biggest fall from
grace of all time.
Like Shakespeare,
the Greek mythology have stories of from
king to peasant.
I mean,
this is a literal story of being bill
Cosby,
beloved,
powerful,
rich,
beyond imagination to inmates throwing
hot dog,
stale hot dog buns at your face.
Well,
the guy was a fucking prolific predator.
The stories of what that guy
did was really remarkable.
I mean,
really astounding stuff.
Actually have some clips.
Um,
this one is really incredible.
It's a clip of from his old show,
the cosby show,
beloved,
by all where he talks about he's doing a
barbecue and he's like.
And his wife was like,
isn't it so nice how everyone's getting
along after they were fighting?
And he goes,
hey,
it's,
it's the secret is my barbecue sauce.
She's like,
oh,
you're kidding.
He's like,
oh,
I'm dead serious.
And he doesn't smile.
His face is like dead pan.
He's sinister sounding.
And he continues.
He goes,
oh no,
I'm dead serious.
You ever notice when you have my
barbecue sauce that everyone gets
happier and gets a little too fondly?
I'm dead serious and,
and he continues and she goes,
stop it and,
and,
and you almost feel like she's being
creeped out,
but I believe this.
She's like,
stop it.
And he's like,
no,
I'm serious.
I've got the clip.
I'd like to show you.
Yeah,
let's watch it.
Um,
and then at the end of the clip,
the kids are eating the barbecue and he
comes and takes it away from them real
fast.
Implying that it is not a joke.
And so here,
let me,
let me.
I mean,
this shit is unbelievable.
It really is truly something baby.
A bill cosby,
special bbq sauce.
I wonder if he was.
This is definitely anecdotal from his
real life outside the show.
Watch his face.
Work things out for themselves.
It's my barbecue sauce.
Barbecue sauce.
Haven't you ever noticed after my
barbecue sauce?
After awhile when it kicks in,
they get all huggy bugging.
I'm dead serious.
Haven't one of my people want to get
right home.
Let me do something else.
I got a cup of it up on the night table.
Correct.
I got a cup of it,
said breathing.
Somebody talks to his victims.
Chicken to these people are going up and
absence is threatening her.
So here's the rest of the chicken
chicken.
Wow.
How is that like family content?
You know,
I think it was just like wacky at the
actual context.
Well,
even the context at the time is that
he's put a drug and the bar,
I mean there's no other way to.
They haven't worked anything out for
themselves.
That's all on my barbecue sauce.
You seen.
Oh,
stop it.
Stop anything.
In fact,
I got a big bucket of barbecue sauce in
the room.
Are you coming up or do I have to force?
You know.
And so somebody,
of course I'm some genius.
Um,
his name is,
uh,
you God made an edit that I like to
share with you guys.
That really captures the moment more
accurately I would say.
Let's see.
Yeah,
it
certainly is nice to see them work
things out for themselves.
Take up the left track for themselves.
When it kicks in,
they get all her buggy hockey.
Pocky stops,
right?
It's a threat.
What can we look at his body language?
I got a cup of chicken before.
If this was a scene from like a horror
chicken,
he's like a serial killer or something.
I wouldn't be surprised if they played
this in court during this trial.
We got a sound bite.
The lawyer said like,
you know in every joke there's a little
bit of truth.
Right?
Exactly.
Yeah.
I think that's a good legal argument.
We got a sound bite.
Some of these barbecue sauce clips.
I feel like these have a perpetual use.
I love this barbecue sauce.
I'm telling you.
That was.
That was courtesy of a eat.
God actually.
You know what?
I don't know how long the store's been
been in the news,
but this is eight years old.
Sorry,
I'm literally dyslexic out dyslexia it
out three years old.
I actually,
you know what I did?
I cut the eight and half in my mind.
[inaudible] it's three.
Half of eight.
Like literally if you cut it in half,
you see it three.
So you completed that.
I completed the three in my mind.
I know it's a really incredible stuff.
Is it not?
Not.
I'm going to say this to you whenever I
want to get it on and now you're not.
Be like the barbecues outside.
Why don't we go on upstairs?
Somebody's either got the bomb.
Mccune saw sand,
two new meaning of lube it up.
When do I have here?
Either you want to go.
So all the songs you sing found a little
sleeping,
a little,
uh,
unconscious.
A little,
uh,
Amnesia and so on.
The sauce play some creepy music guys.
But it's all on the sauce.
You've seen either you feeling a little
sleepy,
a little amnesia,
you know,
lay down,
close your eyes for get it all happen.
You're kidding,
right?
Oh No.
Tom,
the sauce.
I guess we have no creepy music.
Oh,
I feel like the moments gone enough.
I'm on the sauce.
Wow.
Welcome to Papa's house.
Oh,
that's a man that knows how to saw some
pie on the sauce for him too.
Now let's all give praise,
by the way,
to Hannibal burress,
who,
who by the way,
let's all remember the Hannibal.
Did this explosive standups several
years ago,
somebody just filmed it on their phone,
everything,
right?
It wasn't on comedy central or anything.
He was just at a nightclub and somebody
filmed it on the phone and put it online
and it made headlines because bill
[inaudible] Hannibal was like,
Fuck Bill.
Cause we always tell them black people
what to do from like a,
from like a pet is still always being
like black,
black people need to bootstrap
themselves up like me.
He's like,
he's a fucking rapist.
That was the first time I never heard
that.
I didn't know that.
He was like,
seriously go google bill cosby raped and
see what you find.
And that was the catalyst that started
this whole thing here.
Let's watch that clip.
So start me to probably,
I think,
I mean that was really a prolific.
Not Prolific,
but it was a monumental.
It may have.
Yeah,
animal God damn
it was great but built stage crazy that
he broke down and a great job too.
But it was shocking at the time.
Well that's a ballsy claim to make about
it.
Anyone publicly to be like,
Oh yeah,
but you rape people.
It's like,
what?
I can't really say that.
Wow,
that's great.
Credible stamats,
puddling teflon image.
Middle States.
When people,
they rape allegations,
call me captain,
kick him out.
That shit is upset.
If you didn't know about it,
trust me.
You leave in Google,
Bill Cosby,
right?
Right.
Okay.
Stand
up.
And um,
yeah,
that's really incredible stuff.
So shout out to the animal.
Got Goddamn.
Well,
let's throw it to a break.
We will be right back after these
messages from me out of my mouth,
from the sponsors on a paper through my
mouth to you.
We keep them fresh,
we keep them and we keep them exciting.
So you're not going to want to skip it
because it's really fun and exciting.
Really entertaining copyrights.
We'll be back after that to talk about
drake creeping up.
Millie,
Bobby Brown,
some Papa John Updates and so much more.
So please stay with us on the h three
podcast,
fully enlightened shade.
How could you disrespect me?
Like that experience?
Thank you.
To capterra for sponsoring us.
We're all bound to face unexpected
hurdles at work.
Don't let finding the right software be
one of them.
Two thousand 19 is quickly approaching
and you do not have time for unexpected
hurdles to do rail.
You Alright?
Capterra is a website that organizes all
of the software you need to get the job
done.
They got a free ebook for you called the
big book of free software,
which you can download for
free@capterradotcomslashhthreecapterra.com
is a free resource to help you find the
software you need for your business and
with health information on over 300
different software tools that their big
book of free software.
I said big view,
a really big can I help you find a
completely free tool to test today and
it's absolutely free so you won't have
to ask your boss for a penny.
I can tell you right now.
These guys asked me for a penny F no.
I said go to Capterra.
It's free.
They're there.
You'd ask me for money and he's a good
kid.
I like him a lot.
Whether you're looking for a new project
management tool,
recruiting software and email marketing
solution.
CAPTERRA's big book of free software has
got something for you.
Visit [inaudible] dot com slash h three
Ted day to get your free copy of the big
book of software that's Capterra C,
a,
p e t e R,
r a.com/h
three cap terra.
They usually now,
many people say that Jesus was nailed at
the cross,
but actually he wasn't ever nailed to
the cross.
That's revising of history.
What he was now till was because it has
that profound.
People think that he bore the cross in
suffering and pain,
but actually the truth was that he took
the two quips apart and dual brushed his
mouth up to heaven and eternal bliss
because this is the best toothbrush you
will ever put in your mouth.
Now here's the deal.
It vibrates.
It tells you when to switch sides.
It helps you keep your dirty,
disgusting,
mouth kissable and fresh and clean them.
Take it from me.
I went to the dentist for a cleaning and
the first time in three years I said,
dentists,
I come out of here every time clean as a
whistle.
He looked at me in the eyes,
he says,
well,
let's see,
check,
and he fist bumped me the dentist,
fist bump because my mouth is that
clean.
I can endorse this product.
This is the only toothbrush I'll use.
It's got the softest bristles in the
game.
It's electric to make sure you get the
best brush possible.
I caves track.
I mean,
what more do you need to say,
I endorse this product,
I love this product,
and it can be yours right now for just
$25.
You go try to buy an electric toothbrush
of this caliber for $25.
Get out of town.
You're not going to find it for less
than $2,000.
That's an exaggeration,
but they're very expensive to go to get
quip.com/h
three right now and get your first
refill.
Pack free.
Have a quick electric toothbrush.
That's your first refill.
Pack free at [inaudible] dot com slash h
three g e t dot q u I p.com/coby
h three.
No clubby,
no.
Obviously it's just get quip.com/age
three.
You guys know that I love me undies
because it is the softest,
most luxurious underwear on the market
today.
You're using those nasty old cotton
underwear that you've been using for 10
years that your parents bought you when
you went off to college and you sell
them and got new underwear.
Well,
now's the time.
Let me show you how comfortable me
undies is.
This whole time I've been sitting having
a mega wedgie sitting comfortably with
this shoved up my balls and my ass and
that's how soft and luxurious and
flexible and breathable it is that I
could sit here during the mega wedgie
and not even know it looked.
You know?
I mean,
I'm fine with that.
So that's a real time demonstration and
I don't think you need any.
I think the copy speaks for.
Don't need to say anything else,
but I will because they're gonna make
they make me do that membership.
They've got a new membership plan.
Guys.
Members pay less for everything on the
[inaudible] website and special member
of pressure.
That means if you want a second pair of
Meundies,
a Bralette or lounge pants,
you'll pay less than anyone.
Membership comes with no strings
attached.
You can switch styles,
skip the month or cancel anytime.
Guys,
you know I love these underwear.
They come with a 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee,
so if you don't love them,
you send them back,
they incinerate them and you get a full
refund.
Guys,
it's simple as that.
We've got an offer for our listeners.
Mandy's got a great offer for first time
purchasers.
When you purchase any of these,
you get 15 percent off and free shipping
as a no brainer.
Folks get 50 percent off a pair of the
most comfortable underwear you'll ever
give yourself an atomic wedgie all the
way up to your Nipples,
folks.
That's right.
Do you get 15 percent off your first
pair?
Free Shipping and 100 percent
satisfaction guaranteed.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash h three.
Folks,
that is me,
undies.gov/h
three.
Welcome back guys.
Thanks for sticking around.
I hope you had a great time during that
commercial break,
which we try our best to keep fresh and
exciting every time.
By the way,
what do you guys think of a little
preview of crash the new Hoodie?
This is part of the winter collection
right next year.
Oh,
this is next year.
20 19.
Wait,
I thought.
Well at any rate,
new logo,
the TF three.
Let me actually let me know what you
guys think about it.
I fucking love this and it is amazing.
We have a new manufacturer who's like
crushing it with this stuff.
I'm,
I love it.
I love.
Yes.
Isla Isla been working super hard on all
this stuff and it's really nice to see
it all come to fruition.
Do you have to work like a year ahead of
time?
Yeah,
and that's like impossible.
So we're trying to catch up now.
Right?
So we're trying to work on,
on all 20,
19 and it's like how,
what do you plan now for next winter?
I know it's crazy thing,
but I want.
You've been working so hard you and,
and either works closely with two.
We have to teddy fresh employees that
are,
and they're really having a great thing
and I mean this,
I love this and I love the new logo.
We worked really hard kind of trying to
concepts of new logos.
We want to like,
have like a strong branding element that
wasn't a teddy bear.
Yeah.
Amazing.
I want it to not always have to use the
teddy bear and have somebody more
graphic like the,
the.
Yeah,
you've got to.
It's like you got it.
But that I don't know,
just is a home run and I love how the
um,
the Hoodie has like the inverted colors.
Like the inlay is different color.
So.
Cool.
You're also wearing our shorts.
Oh yeah.
Eat.
And in the uh,
it's enough stuff.
Drake,
31 years old,
hip hop,
mega superstar,
drake,
millie,
Bobby Brown and 11 remotely famous 11
from stranger things.
Uh,
14 years old.
Um,
it turns out that they are,
I don't know,
relate not their friends.
And I find it interesting not only you
have everyone on the Internet.
Yeah.
Well,
and for good reason I think because I
find it now,
first of all,
now spot speaking as a 33 year old band.
I'm close to drake and age.
How old is he?
Okay.
Now what purpose?
What value would you get out of texting?
A 14 year old girl.
I'm not really sure how much.
I'm not really sure.
I can't say,
but then when she goes on to describe
their relationship,
I not only raised one eyebrow,
raised both my eyebrows.
At first I heard about it because I
think he invited her to a show and there
was like a picture of them together and
it was all cool.
It was clear that he is a funnel for
which who is not cool.
Like she seems like such a bad as on the
show.
Yes.
And she was a fan of him so all good.
But then now it's like,
well she did these interviews or she's
getting into details of like we taxed
and we talk and he says that I missed
you so much and I tell him I miss him
and I imagined him,
him,
him at home being like,
no,
shut up.
Know.
Um,
and there's another one where she's
like,
so I met him at a hotel and then we went
out for dinner and then we're hanging
out every night for three days and now
we text each other all the time and we
love each other and I'm just like whoa.
And is giving her advice on like boys
and dating?
Yeah.
And he's just got to be at home being
like,
God.
All I'm saying is drake,
be careful because Papa's house is not.
We don't need another.
We didn't want them to Papa's house.
Barber's house.
Don't need another inmate that here.
Let's watch some of these videos.
This is the first video that came out of
her talking about him.
Let me throw this up.
This is a little excerpt of the video
for you.
Gosh,
he's not my crush.
Okay,
let me get this straight.
He's like a brother.
His brother.
I met drake in an Australian hotel.
I was touring and he was touring to and
he honestly,
his managers,
this came up to my dad and said try it
gloves the show come to a show tonight.
And I was like,
oh my goodness.
My dad honestly it was on t mobile,
the French team mobile trying to get as
Wifi from Australia.
He was like,
I don't know who drake is,
was like,
are you joking me?
Drink Shit.
He wants to see me.
I was like,
okay,
we're going.
So I like got my outfit prepared at,
went there and he was such a fan boy and
it was such a fan girl that we honestly,
we text all the time now.
He helps me with everything,
like just life lessons.
Um,
he's amazing.
He's a great human being.
And we went to dinner afterwards and we
had dinner the next day and then we met
in Sydney hotline bling is one of my
favorites.
The part where she goes,
we met for dinner and then we kept
meeting for dinner next thing all the
time.
Texting all the time.
I mean,
again,
it's just,
I feel like from perspective,
I
see why she doesn't think it's a 14 year
old girl.
Yeah.
And she thinks she's an adult,
like you know,
at that age you're like,
I'm an adult at 14.
Yeah.
And she definitely has that air.
She's a sweet girl.
She's amazing.
But you can tell she thinks she's
very mature.
Fourteen year old too.
But being 30 years old,
being 31.
And from our perspective it looks really
weird.
Os being closer in age.
Do you love me?
Are you writing?
Do you have a cell next to cars?
Be You love me?
Yeah.
And so anyway,
that's part one.
Okay,
that's fine.
Um,
Kiki,
are you 14?
Do you love me?
Do you have a prison cell next to cars
be?
Um,
so that's part one.
Welcome to Papa's house.
Here's part two.
This one just,
I guess came out about your relationship
with drake.
Tell me about that.
People have such as these a red carpet
fucking interviews.
Yeah.
They like don't bat an eye and they're
like,
oh yeah.
Tell me about your relationship with
drake.
What about your religion?
Drank.
I think you want to tell me about your
friendship.
How did this all come about?
I love him.
I met him in Australia and he's honestly
so fantastic and a great friend and a
great,
a great role model.
You know,
we text,
we just text each other the other day
and he was like,
I miss you so much.
It was like,
I miss you more.
He's coming.
He's like,
Oh,
don't fucking say that guy's shows how
innocent and immature she is firsthand.
You,
you cannot.
As a 31 year old man text a 14 year old
girl that's not related to you.
I miss you so much.
[inaudible] cannot.
And the fact that she doesn't understand
that so little that even to her saying
that doesn't look weird.
Um,
no she hasn't.
She,
I think she even made like a statement
about it really just like a,
you guys can't tell me who can be my
friend.
Just stopped making it awkward.
Okay.
But that's why I'm saying I don't think
she can understand at her age how weird
it is.
No,
no.
Yeah,
I agree.
Yeah.
I feel,
you know.
Yeah.
What can I say?
A lot of people say he's grooming her.
That's just such a weird state.
I don't know the term.
What is grown.
Basically what it means is that like
he's preparing her or when she turns 18
so that he can legally hit it.
Yeah.
Apparently he four years of dedication.
Allegedly
he's done that with a,
some kind of 16 year old girl.
Ian Was Ian's the keeper of culture and
knowledge,
but I don't want to get the facts mixed
up.
But allegedly,
and this is from a second hand report,
but there was some sticks.
16 girl he met when she was 16 and when
she turned 18 they started dating.
Really?
Yeah.
Allegedly and I may maybe false.
So again,
take everything I say here as pure fact
and not speculate them.
Kiki,
are you riding?
Are you 14?
Welcome to Papa's house.
The other wrinkle in of this is like
people are saying,
um,
he's just helping her out because he was
a child star to.
Right.
Okay.
You know what I mean?
That's sweet.
That's a sweet angle here.
You want to see what she.
Yeah.
What'd she say?
Why do I say,
Oh,
you gotta close your window.
Let me finish this.
Let me see what.
I'm definitely gonna.
Go and see him.
I'm so excited.
Yeah.
And Drake.
That's awesome.
What advice does he give you?
Like what does he say about boys?
He helps me
and then it's like,
why does it always gotta go there?
Like,
damn,
we talk about other shit.
What are you going to go there?
We always talk about boy.
Yeah,
he's great.
He's wonderful.
I love the advice with boys,
you know,
that stays in the text messages.
Alright.
So what else we got here?
So she said,
why you got to make a lovely friendship.
Your headline,
you guys are weird.
For Real.
I'm lucky to have people in business
expand.
Yeah.
She,
I mean again,
like you said,
she just,
she,
yeah,
like you said you.
Yeah.
But the child star angle is a,
is a valid defense,
you know,
and I'm not accusing the guy have
anything.
It's just a lot.
But you know,
but it's hard to explain that.
Him texting her,
I miss you very much.
Yeah.
She's like,
and he initiated it.
She was like,
he texted me out of the blue.
I miss you very much.
And I was like,
I miss you too.
[inaudible].
I was just reciprocating.
Kiki,
are you 14?
Are you riding?
Get some quaaludes in that Jello when.
Let's get barbecue sauce.
Head on upstairs.
All right,
well,
there you have it.
Drake and millie.
Bobby Brown.
Next up,
we've got stories for days,
folks.
This is the h three podcast experience.
We've got stories for days.
We've got the best stories people.
This is my trump impression.
Now we've got the best stories.
People the best.
Okay.
You come here once you do a trump
impression.
This show is gone.
I'm
not criticizing,
I'm just doing an impression.
Listen,
we've got the best stores.
People.
I got the hand motion,
right?
We've got the.
Believe me,
we've got the best stores.
doing a trump impression is like so many
bad ones,
unlike mine,
the handmade.
It's a really fun impression because of
all this.
Just show as really gone downhill.
Yeah.
Well along with everything else,
so I'm fucking right there.
Believe,
believe me,
they actually podcast.
Believe me,
the HCD podcast.
It's the best.
Okay.
Got The best stories.
The best people take her from me.
I would know.
Trust me.
It's the best.
Was that good?
I mean,
obviously the voice Jimmy Fallon's,
cold bear has by far the worst.
I cannot stand coal bears trump
impression mostly because he thinks it's
so good and he talks so slow.
It's like,
oh my God.
It's like dude,
like talks like this is his intros are
good,
but then the impressions that were so.
It just slows the show down.
He could.
I was like this,
ah,
at,
believe me,
this show is that bass?
I don't know.
That's actually the best impression
you've done so far.
Have Cole bear doing trump really solid.
Thank you Dan.
Hey,
there you go.
I got something up my sleeve.
I just need like three layers of
separation from the source oppression
and then it's good.
Anyway.
Well let's get the fuck on with it.
Papa John.
Is it the house and an effort to
distance themselves?
Do it.
By the way,
Papa John's the company is unlike a
mutiny.
I've been watching the show,
the profit.
So the pro here,
this is gonna make sense in the follow
up with me because the profit is this
guy a marcus lemonis and he's like this
business guru and what he does is he
goes and invests in company and helps
them become profitable.
He sees the potential in them,
but the business owners are really.
They're just fucking dumb.
Like Nathan for you in real reality.
Right?
And the problem is usually the companies
have an interesting product or an
interesting market share or something
like that that he can work with,
but the owner is always just like,
just so fucking stupid.
Like it's really a lot of common sense
stuff.
He's like,
all right,
so you guys,
I see you profitted half a million
dollars last year,
but somehow you still lost $300,000
in debt and the owner's like,
yeah,
well I bought a $300,000
truck to help promote them or something
like that.
And that's a real one.
Yeah.
Are there like a.
he's got this big trucks thing outside
of their office.
He's like,
well it's a half a million truck.
I've got a big discount on that.
Marcus is like,
you gotta sell the truck though.
Well I did sign up for that breakdown
for that or it's always like a,
Oh man.
It's always like,
this is a really common one.
He goes and talks to all the employees
and they're all amazing and super hard
working and they're like,
yeah,
he's never here.
He just ever comes here.
The owner,
he just never comes here.
He's not involved at all.
Oh.
He's like,
okay,
so I need you to come to work five times
a week.
Oh,
I did.
Well I did sign up for that.
Okay.
It's always the same dumb shit.
So a funny show.
Well anyway,
my favorite episodes is when it becomes
a full on mutiny and it's so juicy,
so he comes in at the request of the
owner and the owner is such a buffoon.
He's so incompetent that he makes a pact
with the employees and they all turned
against the owner who called him and
asked him and then he gets all defensive
because often he'll give equity to the
employees and then it's like.
And then they're always like,
fuck you,
you're not my boss anymore.
Suck my Dick.
I hate you.
They actually have conversations and
it's so good.
Or the owner will come in and he's like,
I don't like how you're doing this,
whatever.
And then the employee who now has equity
will say,
well,
you're not my boss.
Fuck you.
Marcus comes in and he's like,
well yeah,
he's right.
Fuck you.
You suck.
And then they always go like,
oh,
well I,
I,
it's my company and I'm going to run it
the way I am.
And the market is like,
well,
you wrote it the way you are.
Then this business is going to be out
of.
You're going to be closing the doors in
two days because you don't know how to
run a business and it's so great.
So that's what's happening in Papa
John's.
There's a full on a mutiny at Papa
Johns.
He hasn't been outed.
His faces off all of the branding.
Remember Papa John Built this company.
He is fucking name right now.
It's Steve Papa Steve's house.
Welcome to Steve's house.
So there were moving his face even at
the headquarters.
They're doing a huge makeover at the
headquarters where they're removing his
face off the welfare check.
It's not worth the money they're
spending on all.
Well,
they're betting well,
they must be hurting again.
They're in like full panic mode and so
they've even gone as far as to remove
the apostrophe from Papa John's Papa
John's international filed paperwork
about the new spelling and brand imagery
with the US patent and trademark office
in late August.
Removing the possessive apostrophe and
Papa Johns would in theory provide a
more distance between the company and
its founder so it doesn't look like he
owns the business.
That is the dumbest shit.
The funny name.
So it's bumper John's without
unimpressed by it.
It doesn't make sense.
It's a,
it's a possessive s.
his name is Papa John.
So what is the [inaudible] indicates the
basic grammar that I do know.
Not grammatically correct.
Yeah.
Isla is,
she's fluent in English and um,
so anyway,
the apostrophe is out.
That faith is out and they have released
this heart wrenching.
I'm really powerful movement.
Did you,
do you like the,
you know,
look so lame.
It's not down.
Not the Papa John.
I know.
And love by the way.
They are also removing the better
ingredients.
Better Pizza I read.
That's a classic level by the way guys.
It's not that fucking serious you're
selling pies.
But anyway,
save that because they made this ad that
they posted on their twitter and it's
like a whole campaign about like a,
we're so sorry.
We are so disappointed.
We have to do better.
And it's like the saddest,
most emotional shit ever.
And I would like to play that for you
now with your permission.
Actually,
I don't need your permission.
You have no control over the show.
I hope you'll enjoy it.
So they compiled a bunch of tweets that
they got.
Yeah.
Huh.
You know what?
I wonder if it's really hurting their
business or they or they're freaking out
because they're getting like social
media backlash.
Well,
the easiest way to look at this stock
thought value,
Papa John's.
I mean people who looks like they're.
I mean it looks pretty well actually in
the five days.
Okay.
Hang on,
let me,
let me open this up here.
This is the one year graph you guys can
see.
It looks like they took a big hit
recently from the Papa.
Okay,
let's go to five years.
Let's just get.
Oh yeah,
they took a big hit.
Let's go max years.
Let's see.
The historical data here.
Okay.
That's not that helpful.
Let's go five years.
So you can see,
do one year,
one year they took a big hit from Papa,
Papa,
John,
but they're climbing back and I think
yeah,
I guess see,
it's hard to know if it's from their
efforts or people are just over it and
they want people to again,
they just want pizza,
you know?
But they're like,
no,
it's an apostrophe like that.
A pause,
freak,
genius.
We made a billion dollars.
I just looked it up and I see an article
that says it was from the beginning of
August that their sales overall,
nationally,
it was down to seven percent.
I mean that.
That is significant.
I mean it's not as much as I expected it
on.
It's not a huge difference,
but it's.
The old logo is superior.
I agree.
Just like their pizza.
Anyway,
I'm.
Here we go.
We heard you papa John's.
I am so disappointed in this company.
I'll never order it.
Neil again.
So it's like all this to eight.
I'd rather have frozen pizza then racist
pizza.
They're really owning it.
Like they're actually like railing the
original pop up because they're being
like,
we are race.
We weren't racist pizza.
But that was,
that was,
that was that fucking guy who made this
company that we're all riding.
Racism is disgusting and I won't support
it.
The Leaf poppage nice name.
Remember when we were actually making
progress in civil rights issues,
you expected better from Papa John's.
Why is this?
Why is the music of like a suicide
prevention?
It's like Papa John's.
The company is on suicide watch purpose.
David Papa Steve's on suicide watch.
You expected better from Papa John's.
So did wait.
What does he make of all this was
sitting at home watching this shit.
He wants to be furious.
Yeah.
Papa's into what is both.
Think about this a little too late on
this.
Blaming players for poor sales with dog
whistle racism with a half move.
Yeah.
It's just a bunch of these kinds of
tweaks.
I will not give you any more money.
I don't know what anything will do to
earn my business ever again.
Won't put another diamond to Papa
John's.
Not the poor company.
Until you change your policies,
pitiful.
Look in the mirror.
Stop the flip and blame and do better.
Thank you for your anger.
It's almost like pathetic.
How like a.
it's like stand up for yourself,
Papa.
John,
thank you for your anger.
Thank you for your criticism and thank
you for your honesty.
I'm going to call the police.
I think Papa John's on suicide watch.
I don't want to get an officer over
there to the headquarters.
Not going to hurt themselves.
The whole company,
the whole company.
Thank you for your honesty is making us
better.
Just like our pizza.
Better ingredients,
better pizza.
We already have the best pizza,
but your honesty is making us as people
better.
What did I go to Papa John's sitting at
home like Steve,
what did I do to deserve this
disrespect?
Just by company.
I built this company with my own hands.
I tossed the dough.
I made the ingredients.
What did I do to deserve this disrespect
from you?
Let's look at my son Bowl.
What is my son bought to do?
He was meant to inherit this pizza and
bio.
Pair me with that music.
You guys for Christ sake.
My son,
Beau was to inherit this pizza empire.
Oh,
seriously?
Both lost like everything.
My son,
he's a good boy.
He was meant to inherit this pizza.
Why?
If you had to deal with his dad,
but it was like,
at least I'm going to get this.
Yes.
At least that.
But now,
now ball is not in the house.
Neither is the walk.
Test respect.
Stevie,
you're my trusted colleagues now.
I can trust you more than anyone.
You're going to remove the apostrophe.
It's my company.
It's.
It's in the name of my trust him brother
rather stately bop.
I sit at home.
When I think about my mistakes,
I maybe I said the n word on a
conference.
We've got the best pizza.
I built it with my hands and the sauce,
the sauce,
Alfredo sauce,
my son.
I'll Fred Fred stuff,
and now I'm disgraced in the eyes of the
world,
the Papa John's.
The NFL doesn't bother me.
Butter,
garlic sauce.
Phasey.
I love the butter garlic sauce and no
running ads on twitter.
You never portray the family.
I feel for you as the Godfather,
Papa,
John,
and now what do you.
What's next?
You're going to rub off the fact that
the guy that's buying shots and know
that you've got to get rid of the better
pizza,
better ingredients to serve.
This is inheritances.
Hit me with the puppy in the house.
Welcome.
Well,
you book.
Oh my God,
I can't do that for hours,
is what they got funneled the best movie
ever.
It is.
It really is.
Because you've made it.
I mean,
yeah,
that's really a controversial statement
too about that was really brave of you
to come out and say that.
So brave.
Nobody else agrees with that,
but I'm.
You're athletic.
You're saying.
I'm like,
really the best.
Not just,
Oh,
it's the best.
You know why it's like,
is it really the best?
But I think it is.
Well,
I'll tell you why it's the best and it's
simple.
It's all,
and this is why I love Casa so much.
It's just good acting a good story and
that's it.
It's pure cinematic beauty.
It's beautifully directed,
acted and written.
There's no special effects.
There's no gimmicks.
It's just beautiful cinema,
you know,
and you're suck.
Then every from scene to scene,
you are firmly and golf.
I love the first,
like 20 minutes or whatever the wedding
you come to me,
Stevie us to be.
Is that his name?
Stevie.
Steve.
Steve,
you come to me on the day of my
daughter's wedding and you ask,
can you be CEO?
And I say to you,
Steve,
ricky,
Richie has do.
What did I do to deserve this
disrespect?
My son,
Beau,
he was teased all throughout high
school.
He was meant to have this path.
Right,
and you'll take it from him,
but we never did anything like that.
My son Boldo,
he was gonna.
It was a pizza.
Brent's now it's pizza.
You think Bowie is going to be like
Michael and just ruthlessly to control
the Papa John's empire?
That'd be amazing.
I want a three part trilogy about Papa.
Can you play that music?
We just love it.
The Godfather music.
Now I'm over to it.
I just want to watch the godfather
though.
Did we watch enough of this now?
If you close this?
Definitely.
I have some.
Shake my head.
Pray for you guys to do better.
Yeah.
Moving forward.
Well,
what?
We didn't finish it.
Oh,
I guess that's it.
I love other posturing of like war on
suicide watch.
We don't have any plans or we're not
telling you anything.
Just that were on suicide watch.
Yeah.
There wasn't really a promise at the end
to do better or anything was there.
It was just like there is something like
what?
The values.
You want me to open this io?
Yeah,
you got it open right?
Here you go.
Our core values,
they link to this.
This is a film you want me to read this
here?
Hit Me with the godfather music.
I was appointed the CEO of Papa John's
earlier this year.
As the new CEO,
I want to share the values that will
drive the transformation of Papa John's.
I stated my career in pizza business 25
years ago because pizza brings people
together.
Unlike that piece of shit.
Papa Johns who was brought the
foundation of everything we are to the
ground.
I found a home at Papa John's where
people from all backgrounds work side by
side.
Every Papa Johns is 120,000
corporate and franchise team members
around the world.
We stand for equity,
fairness,
respect,
and
are most important.
Ingredient is people.
Will they have people in their pizzas?
That's kind of a revelation when I
became CEO.
I want to do this in the godfather
voice,
but it doesn't make sense.
That's going to be too slow.
It's going to be when I became CEO in
January in diversity,
equity and inclusion became one of my
top priorities.
What began began as a committee of
passionate team members has grown into a
company wide effort to realize our
values.
He says,
uh,
he says here,
let go up.
When I became CEO,
diversity equity inclusion became my top
priority.
What about selling pies?
You fucking idiot.
We run in a.
are we running the acl?
You or a pizza franchise?
Christ and independent cultural audit.
I,
along with Papa John's,
a leader's visited Atlanta,
Los Angeles.
Dallas.
He had to get.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Recently published leadership team,
completed unconscious bias training.
Wow.
That sounds vulgar.
Uh,
recently.
personally committed to adding more
diversity.
Guys.
It's fucking pizza.
Just sell supplies for Christ's sake.
Does anyone care?
We're assembling a special advisory
group comprises of nationally respected
diversity,
equity,
and inclusion experts to help guide us.
It's fucking by.
We're kicking off the development of two
key longterm initiatives.
Papa John,
my minority owned franchise expansion
and development program.
The fuck does that mean?
What does that mean?
They're just given damp.
Papa really did a lot of damage just
given away franchises.
What did I tell?
I said the n word on a conference.
Call it good that signed.
Sincerely.
See this trail?
I will never forget.
Everyone's like,
get on with it.
Whatever.
I'm there you have it.
A heart wrenching.
This,
the trilogy.
Where are we in the trilogy?
Is this part two or part three was the
part two that was probably two or three
poles apart.
Part three is gonna suck and it's going
to be weird.
The new brand who's going to wear it and
everyone's just gonna.
Forget about Papa.
Yeah,
you know that in the godfather when he's
like sitting outside and dies and
there's like the laundry's on the line
and he's like,
just chilling in his backyard.
Retired playing with the kids.
That's what Papa John Shatner's doing
right now.
Not to have a heart attack and fall over
and fucking die.
Well,
he'll always have the pizza mansion.
Yeah,
Kong.
Oh Man,
dude,
you guys are gonna.
Love this story.
This is honestly one of the best,
most cold blooded fuck it and cut throat
things I've ever seen in my life.
Um,
this Republican candidate for Congress,
I'm trying to think of.
I have it backwards.
Well,
anyway,
this guy who's,
I don't,
I forget whose party or what.
That doesn't really matter,
but a congressman is running and his
opponent goes to his family recruits
five of his siblings,
brothers and sisters,
and they star and this hit job
commercial against their brother.
Their called the uh,
go go sards.
And um,
I'm coining a new phrase right now.
You just got go hard because I have
never seen.
It's so cold blooded day.
You've got to see this.
It's crazy.
Fuck me.
So these are all his siblings just
talking shit on him.
And then at the end they do a little
doop doop twist on you,
closer to the congressman.
Isn't doing anything to help rural
America.
Paul's absolutely not working for his
district.
If they care about healthcare,
they care about their children's
healthcare.
They would hold the family's fucked up.
They care about jobs.
They would hold him to account if he
actually cared about me.
So far it doesn't say I ruined the
surprise because yeah,
I ruined the surprise for everybody by.
They'll get out of that field like you
like you've actually in that field all
the time.
Oh,
you caught me out in the field and
nature.
Oh,
hi.
There was just in nature.
Jennifer Arizona.
I bet he'd be fighting for source of
security for better access to
healthcare.
I better he.
I bet he would be researching what is
the most insightful water policy so
angry to feel the environment of Arizona
sustain itself and be successful and
he's not listening to you and he's
doesn't have your interests at heart.
My name is tim goes sour.
David.
Joan goes,
are to go.
Sorry Jennifer,
go star.
Paul goes,
here's my brother.
My brother and I endorsed Dr.
Brill,
Dr.
Brill wholeheartedly.
Endorse Dr David.
Root for Congress
is that fucking quote,
this guy,
Dr Burrell don't ever pit me against
him.
That guy is cold blooded and Dr David
Brill do have have siblings.
Did I don't know what that guy's
technique is,
but he's up to some like Dr.
Brill was like,
I'll make him an offer.
He can't refuse what?
That's dude.
He got the first ever go sergeant.
Go starting when your whole family,
when all of your loved ones close to
betray you.
Interesting stuff.
Huh?
I love the top comment on the youtube is
I'm the ghost or thanksgiving.
This year is going to be awkward.
Yeah,
that's an understatement.
God,
seriously.
Someone said this is the new game of
thrones season eight,
trailer Rudel.
All this shit isn't unbelievable.
Like fuck.
Like even if you hate your brother,
right?
Even if you hate your brother,
your brother's sucks and you disagree
with them politically and he's running
for office.
I mean really?
Are you going to go with a feature like
five of them?
Not One.
That's such a bad ass,
like little promotion video.
How did they even put.
How did Dr Fucking evil put that Dr
Brill.
How did they even arranged that?
You know what I mean?
Who came up with it?
They woke up with a horse head in their
bed.
Dr.
Brill sent the mcallen card,
I'll make them an offer.
They can't refuse.
This family hit me with the music.
This goes,
you're going to start this ad.
I thought your brother,
you may not like it.
You'll understand and there'll be a time
when I will do a favor for you.
It's getting tough to do that.
Your throat is saying,
yeah.
Where your throat is over you.
My throat is over that bit as is
everyone listening the comments on this
video,
right?
So funny.
Fucking ghosts are man.
Hey.
Hi Guys.
Hey Gang.
It's me.
Dr.
Brill.
So I'm running against your brother for
Congress and I was just hoping if you
would all be um,
available to fucking destroy your
brother publicly and my commercial.
Absolutely.
Doctor,
are you a savage?
Are you,
are you going to savages?
I'm a total savage.
You know what?
I got to tell you,
I don't know anything about the guy
they're shitting on,
but this Dr.
burdall scares the shit out and I'm not
sure I want him in office because that's
the coldest shit I've ever seen in my
life.
Like even if you can get all the
siblings to make a video about that
twist,
I know and it was made like artfully,
right?
Like Shakespearean,
like even if you could make this,
do you really want to be that guy that
like tore the family apart for a good
political ad?
You know what I'm saying?
It's cold.
I feel like I need the backstory of
what's going on in that either way.
Or is this a fucking uh,
Arizona,
those motherfuckers are crazy in
Arizona.
Shit,
I am Dr.
Brill.
And if you don't vote for me,
I will kill you.
I'm Dr Brill and I will kill your whole
family feud.
Not cast your vote for me.
This,
uh,
coming September.
Hi,
I'm Dr Brill,
the coldest motherfucker you've ever
seen in your life.
I will,
I will.
I will not hesitate to hit those drone
murder buttons.
You know how there's like drones in
Afghanistan bombing people and I endorse
this message.
I endorse our click.
Those drone murder buttons so fast.
That was a huge controversy when Obama
was president because he had all these
drones in Afghanistan,
just like dropping bombs all day,
so he's loved.
Brill is loving that.
I will add.
My name is Dr.
Brill and I pledged to drone strike
American citizens in the United States.
I'm cold blooded as it gets real and you
don't want to mess with me.
Pretty much.
I am Dr.
Brill and if you run against me,
I will ruin your whole life and tear
your family apart and then drone strike
your house.
If I'm elected.
This guy scares the shit out of me.
Damn fucking crazy.
Craziest thing I ever seen.
I mean,
it's like.
It's unbelievable.
Anyway,
what else do we got?
Next door is gone.
This is a quick one.
I love this.
This could only have been Russia,
woman buried and Russian graveyard is
given a five foot high tombstone and the
shape of her favorite iphone.
Well,
there you have it folks.
Apparently that's real.
I don't believe it.
I almost don't believe it,
but there you have it only in Russia,
right?
Only in Russia.
Nowhere else in the whole world.
Could anything like that happen?
I mean,
there you have it,
rest in peace.
They're just covered in snow and I ended
up back on the back.
It even had its like really realistic.
It's got buttons and everything.
Does it have a case?
It might have a case on it.
Yes.
There she is.
Crushing it,
crushing it and crushing it.
Afterlife as well.
So crazy.
They didn't even have you.
What do you call it?
The Barcode?
Yeah.
Barcode.
Give it a scan.
I don't know.
Crushing it.
Yeah.
This girl's amazing.
So that's a really nice.
More than that.
I just thought it was interesting.
Apparently her father built the
tombstone after her death dedicated her.
That's kind of a loving act honestly.
Yeah.
Um,
can I play you something?
I get this voicemail from these fucking.
I hate these people.
They call me sometimes twice a day and
they do this thing where it doesn't even
ring.
It just goes straight to voicemail.
Right.
Hold on,
let me find this fucking thing.
And I'm telling me if you guys have
heard this shit before or if it's just.
I'm actually just calling to let you
know that the business line of credit,
I have preapproved few lives to be
expiring soon.
I'm actually at the end of the year,
so as we're hearing the same exact
message,
really just wanted to reach out to see
plants for the holidays and see if
there's any way we can put this capital
to use for you.
Give me a call if we can go over rates
and terms that I have available.
I can be reached at 800,
six zero,
nine,
four,
seven,
or you can simply call me back on that
number that popped up on your phone.
We'll talk soon.
Have a great day.
God.
Okay.
Hey,
it's Rachel.
Actually just calling to let you know
that the business line of credit,
I have pre approved few lives to be
expiring soon.
What are they even say?
Usually go.
No,
they usually go a good news,
Mr Klein,
you've been preapproved for a million
dollars of credit,
but it's expiring.
It's expiring soon though.
I swear to God.
They've called me 100 times with a year
and I got bad news.
You 1 million leaves.
Do not call and impersonate me and open
a line of credit in my name.
I don't think they know anything about
me except my name and number.
Fucking assholes.
Don't call them guys now.
I've wished that I hadn't played that.
What else we got?
Oh,
your mom's house.
This skin code.
The new board.
This is how you can go through the data.
Oh,
that's funny.
That's a funny observation.
You can like open a chat.
Chat Room Afterlife.
Yeah.
Looking good.
Go up some good.
Love your tombstone.
Thank you.
Um,
we were recently featured on Tom and
Chris.
Tom Segora and Christina p,
the courageous married news couple in
the tri state area.
Better than I married.
And what news?
The 10 minute mark.
Maybe.
These guys are so freaking awesome.
I love them so much.
They have a podcast of your mom's house.
My Mom's house that we were on recently
and I had so much fun.
You guys should go watch that.
Just want to give them a shout out.
It was great.
I also want to say thank you everybody
who sent emails to podcast at h,
three h three productions.com.
I loved all the submissions,
all the questions or the videos or the
pictures,
everything.
Um,
please keep it coming.
Podcasts at h,
three h,
three productions.com.
If you guys have like a reaction,
suggestions to that you want to send.
I love everything.
I love it.
In fact,
I have got some stuff though.
I would love to go over here with you
today
on this one.
And only h three podcasts experience.
Uh,
what do we got from Mom Zang?
Me and my buddy made.
Oh,
this is a new one.
Yeah,
this one's a little tricky.
Let me see.
Oh,
these are all new ones.
Okay.
So wait,
how does this work?
Then you added this one at the top.
I just added to a last night.
If you just scroll down a little bit,
there'll be all the ones that you.
Uh,
okay.
I haven't seen these ones yet,
so I don't want to put them up yet.
A company.
Did you know what the Fuck God damn
company,
if.
How's it going,
boss?
There's a group of people that don't,
not for 100 days.
Plus the reasons are interesting with
like your perspective from Ghia.
Uh,
the no fat is a community online I have
heard of and I'm intrigued by their
activities.
Now these are people that believe that
by not masturbating or looking at
pornography,
they gain superhuman powers essentially.
In fact,
I pulled up,
I was doing some research because I'm
aware of the group,
but this was one of the top post of all
time on the no Phipps subreddit.
And so this is what they outlined
happens to you when you do not
masturbate.
Over the course of 10 years,
my God,
10 years not fucking drinking your own
filth.
Ds Meet Anyway,
five minutes.
Wow.
I'm,
I'm five minutes.
Your heart rate will return back to
normal.
Okay?
Two to three days.
Guilt and shame.
Seems like it is decreasing.
Seven days.
Brain fog will lift.
School will get easier for you.
Fourteen days.
Prolastin also known as,
okay,
they're getting scientific starts to
drop.
Fourteen to 21 days.
Dopamine sensitivity increases.
Thirty days.
Craving and flashbacks will noticeably
reduce 30 days,
60 days.
It becomes rock solid and confidence
keeps rising.
Uh,
60 days.
You might stop giving a fuck what other
people think about what it's like when
your bio facial lotion or something or
all the benefit of like write everything
you wish will have diamond water.
I'm at 90 days considered a full reboot
for most people.
Confident,
still rising.
One hundred 50 days.
Symptoms of severe pied disappear on
prep.
I know what it is,
but I liked the sound of that 200 days.
I feel like every girl wants to fuck me
and I started reading a Bible of this as
far as I can tell isn't a job.
This guy found God after 200 days a one
year.
I don't even know why I was watching
porn a year ago,
two years now.
I have a amazing job and I've never been
happier.
Really.
They'll from not masturbating 10 years.
My life has just been amazing.
Ever since I stopped masturbating.
I'm 10 years.
This guy's dead serious,
which is kind of funny and a little
pathetic,
but if I'm a speaking frankly,
there is an interesting theory and not
masturbating because I do think that
like porn addiction is real and I do
think that like when you look like
looking at porn is really unhealthy
because you do.
It's like when you look at porn and you
just know any finished real fast,
it is kind of like a high.
Like you get this like you know,
if you're like in a bad mood or
whatever.
A lot of guys I think rely on like a
Kurt,
a quick jerk.
I'll quick porn watch as a treatment to
a bad mood.
A lot of guys or a lot of guys that
know,
I think it's very common and so they'll
watch some porn,
they'll jerk one out real quick and then
you're like,
uh,
and then you get on with your day.
But there is really I think something to
this idea that like your dopamine,
your reward levels and shit got all
whacked out and it really is like an
addiction.
And so I do think that there is probably
some good benefits to at least not
looking at porn,
but I've also read that masturbating
daily for guys is healthy because it
helps prevent prostate cancer because
you're constantly,
you know,
pushing everything out of your tubes or
if you let it sit there,
like that's how colon cancer happens to
it because you don't,
the more you ship,
the less likely you are to get colon
cancer because you don't want that stuff
sitting there for so long.
It's the same theory with the a nut
juice.
So I am intrigued,
but at the same time I'm sure that it's
probably not that serious.
Are you gonna know fap?
I'm in,
I'll go.
I'll know fat for like a day.
I'm already at five minutes.
My heartbeat feels pretty normal.
Guilt and shame.
Definitely.
That's two to three days.
So I haven't reached that level yet,
but we all get milestones.
My,
my best record so far is three hours.
So I don't know,
I'm intrigued by it.
I'd like to hear from a no fabric.
I'd like to take a call from somebody
who,
um,
who has gone a long time without
masturbating to Kinda hear there,
you know,
I heard something interesting about Mike
Tyson when he used to go box when he was
young,
like God,
like boxer,
he wouldn't masturbate or have sex for
like months leading up to his fight
because it would get them all crazy.
Kind of interesting.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
Um,
I'm interested,
you know,
they're called fap too,
by the way.
I swear to God and that's what it says
in their fucking description.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Do any of you guys are back there?
Are you in any of this?
Into this?
No.
Flapping,
definitely not.
Absolutely not.
What about Zach and m?
You guys?
I mean,
it's relaxing.
It's looks like it's all know back.
Lots of a sheepish knows frequent
masturbatory.
Yes.
We all are frequent exacerbaters.
I wonder how frequently do you guys
masturbate?
Probably like once a day and Zach and,
uh,
in a interest that he's done it twice
since the show started.
So no,
don't be.
I want to,
I'm,
I'm genuinely curious.
I'm taking a sample here,
I'd say about,
I don't know,
once every two days,
once every two days.
Every two days.
It's pretty conservative.
That's conservative.
You're a young man.
Should be jerking off.
Like fight with Zach.
Just turned 21 and I want to know how
much Ian masturbates.
I feel like he's asleep.
He jerks like eight times a day.
That's a little offensive.
Well,
how am,
to be honest,
I don't know.
Forty eight hour window.
Forty eight hour.
That's pretty responsible.
I'm like once a day.
I guess when I was younger there'll be
days when I was younger there'd be like
eight times in a day.
That wasn't like common,
but some days it's like your Dick
actually gets hurt.
It's like,
Whoa Dude,
you need to get a life,
but you have.
But we've all been there,
right?
Nothing better to do.
I,
I get why the people I get why these
people.
I'm like,
you said,
you know,
intellectually I see that there can be
some benefit to it,
especially with what you were saying
about,
you know,
relaxing your reward center and uh,
well,
and when you jerk off in the middle of
the day,
it can fuck your whole day up.
You know what I mean?
Why?
Because you just get so sleepy and lazy
and then all of a sudden you're like,
you just have no motivation because you
jerked off in the middle of the day.
It's like,
and you're,
you know what I mean?
It's like,
what do you,
where do you go from there?
Take a nap.
I don't know.
No fat.
I'm intrigued.
Good question.
Thank you.
Gift for that.
Uh,
enlightening.
Vigorous debate.
Thank you.
And God bless Ya.
Next up from pee Layton,
I work in the vape industry and I always
listen to your podcasts while I'm here
as a fellow member of the nation.
I would love to hear any commentary you
guys have on the new FDA regulations for
vaping products in regards to packaging
and advertisings and the law to ban
flavors and the epidemic of teen vaping.
Sincerely,
xxx vape wizard for 20 x x x Hashtag
[inaudible] a great question.
So the FDA,
this is
actually quite interesting and then you
would know about this because it affects
you directly,
is that the FDA is banning flavored vape
juices because they say it appeals to
kids.
That is pretty much par for the course
of my pain because they did the same
thing to alcohol and tobacco where they
really restricted how they could market
it because they didn't want it to appeal
to kids.
And frankly I do feel like vaping has
become a really severe gateway drug.
I don't know if you want to say gay or
whatever,
but I haven't seen it firsthand,
but I've heard that a lot of kids in
like middle school and high school,
I walk around with these tiny little
vape pen and actually smoking,
um,
which I find pretty wild because it's
almost like everybody stopped smoking
cigarettes.
They're all like,
we all understand it's not cool.
It's really bad for you.
But now it's almost like there's a new
problem where super accessible and
everyone's like,
oh,
it's not as bad.
So it's okay.
I think we don't really know how bad it
is yet.
Maybe it's not that bad.
Maybe it's not.
Maybe it is.
I don't know,
but I think it's probably a good idea
that,
uh,
what the fuck do I know,
Dan?
What do you think?
I mean,
I'm really of two minds of it because
I'm on the one hand,
you know,
I,
I think,
you know,
obviously it's bad.
I don't know how prevalent it really is
with kids.
Like,
is it more than when we were in high
school kids smoking cigarettes?
Apparently it's,
it is extremely.
Uh,
it's,
it's very,
it's like overwhelming from,
from what I understand.
Again,
I'm,
I'm not
so,
I mean present that that is,
that is probably not good admittedly.
But is it,
I mean,
banning the flavors,
is that really gonna do anything to
prevent that?
You think like it's really specific
flavors,
like a Unicorn.
What I remember when I was a kid,
I would go,
whenever we come to la,
my mom would take me to this candy store
that I loved and the one candy I would
always get,
I loved it so much was bubble gum
cigarettes,
you believe this and it was gum wrapped
in like they had a bunch of powdered
sugar so you could go and it would puff
out sugar.
I think.
I know that it was so cool smoking a
cigarette and I think I forgot that
existed and I used to love it too.
Yeah,
I logged it as a kid and looking back on
that,
it's like,
Whoa,
that's pretty fucked up.
That was my favorite.
I will go get it.
And I thought was so cool.
Every time.
Those are not sure.
Those are band.
Yeah.
I love so.
I Dunno.
I don't know.
What the hell do I know?
Thanks for the question.
A half priced teddy,
teddy friends because you ain't getting
no half off.
Right?
It was full price.
Yeah,
half price.
Did A.
Hey,
my name's Josh.
Had been a huge fan.
You guys are the best youtube channel.
Best Channel on Youtube.
Thank you.
And you know,
I mean,
thank you so much.
Tell me more.
Uh,
well,
not the biggest trend.
I was wondering,
have you ever heard of a movement called
stop a douchebag?
It's a movement in Russia in which a
group of people stop others from parking
and illegal places such as sidewalks,
railroads by approaching them carefully.
Sometimes they will blow up with huge
amounts of ignorance and other will move
straight to physical violence.
If they don't comply then they get a
huge sticker on their windshield.
They have a nice amount of subs.
And was wondering what you guys think.
Does this solution even work?
This is productive or should there be
other actions taken?
Just curious.
Thank you for the kind words,
Josh.
I believe he had said,
and if I can quote him,
you are by far the best channel on
Youtube from Josh half-priced.
Ted,
you are by far the best channel on
Youtube.
He said about us.
Um,
thank you for that.
So let's go.
Actually,
yeah,
I do know about these guys.
Stop a douchebag and actually pulled up
the video and we can watch it together.
Oh,
okay.
Once I have a quick look here.
Yeah.
So I mean apparently in Russia it's a
little more like a medieval.
Like motherfuckers just,
you see the shit,
they're crazy.
There's traffic and there's limited.
So just hopping up on the sidewalk,
it's a little more,
it's a little more lawless probably in
some places in Russia.
So these guys are vigilantes and they're
like,
this is fucked up.
[inaudible] cities.
Our sidewalk don't,
you know,
don't drive on the sidewalk is
dangerous.
Right.
So they call it stop a douchebag and
they were taking vigilante justice into
their own hands,
just like Batman essentially.
Can I ask you why you parked your bus on
the sidewalk?
Okay.
Uh,
he says it's a service bus.
What the service bus.
I can't hear you.
Unfortunately.
We are waiting for some people to get
on.
Okay.
Well,
could you move your bus at least you
parked right on the sidewalk.
People push their shopping carts here.
He doesn't seem to give a fuck.
You won't be able to get around.
Or can you move your truck please?
Thank you.
And they're asking the guy and he does
so there you have it,
vigilante justice,
but sometimes the
blurred defined and I guess that's when
it gets a little while.
Um,
there's a Mercedes that's on the
sidewalk.
They stop him.
He said,
oh,
the guy
says this won't happen again.
I'm late.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
Back your car please.
They say it's almost like catch a
Predator vibe.
It's like,
I wonder if they know these guys in
Russia because he's like,
oh,
you caught me at will never happen
again.
I'm going to pull out.
No,
no,
no.
Back up there saying you can't.
They're not letting them
pull out there making them back up.
I know all people are equal.
All must drive back.
So they send this guy back.
The guy knew what was good for a man.
Well,
let's see if this guy does.
This guy is not having that.
I could tell you right now,
sky was kind of sheepish.
He was like kind of on the road on the
sidewalk.
This guy is fully occupying the
There's a huge line of traffic.
And this guy's driving on this
sidewalk.
I'm running late,
she says,
for a friend's wedding.
Understand,
but can you please back to the roadway
guys?
I need to be at the river.
Go station 20 minutes,
Yada Yada.
At sidewalk on lake.
Do you relative.
You're on a footpath for the blind right
now.
I do understand,
but sometimes things come up.
She said,
oh,
everyone's been really polite.
No.
Oh,
she went around.
I was just running around them.
Oh,
are they going to catch up to her?
So she drew.
Oh really?
So they're chasing after she went around
them and book that out.
And so what they do,
they have these giant stickers that
probably fucks their whole week up.
And I guess what it says in Russian is,
I'm a Douche bag and it's this huge
sticker.
The covers the windshield,
the windshield.
So they pretty much can't drive.
I gotta say they gave them a fair
chance.
It's very vigilante justice.
Let's see how she reacts.
You take that thing off.
Oh my God just keeps driving.
They put it on the passenger side.
They usually put it over the driver's
side.
I think,
let's see,
we've got another one.
Oh,
there's two.
There's several cars.
That whole line.
The day stop a douchebag.
Boom in here.
Just as himself.
Could you back out of your car please?
And there's actually a car behind him.
Stop.
Or I'll put a sticker on your
windshield.
Oh,
he's,
he's pulling.
He's driving into them.
Trying to run them over.
It.
Stopped there saying I'm going to put a
sticker on your windshield.
I'm going to give you fucker stickier.
Now they put it.
So
got it,
got it.
Okay.
Now this is great.
By the way,
is this 23 million views?
So they put the sticker over the
passenger side window.
So there's really no way for him to
drive until he gets off on the driver's
side.
The driver's side.
So yeah,
this guy's totally fucked.
So he's getting out of his car though.
He's not happy.
And he's got.
He's got cargo,
military pants on,
he's throwing a sandals out.
He's getting ready to kick some ass in
those sandals.
This guy scared what's going on?
This guy's fucking scaring me.
Let me grab the knife.
Oh,
he's got a weapon.
He's got like a nunchuck what the funder
was nunchucks what?
They'll get the fuck out of here.
Ugly motherfucker.
Where do I go?
Oh,
he took his nun,
chuck and threw it in the woods because
it's like 20 years.
Oh man,
he's trying to get the sticker off,
but it's not really coming off now.
This guy days.
Fuck,
I don't care where I'm driving and you
see my fucking tag skylight mafia or
something.
And these guys are hardcore.
I've got to say.
I know that there's like a lot of mafia
ties in Russia.
So I,
I,
these guys are pretty brave.
I would say to do this.
I mean,
I don't know much about Russia.
Even regardless,
wouldn't the Mafia.
There's just,
you never know this guy could have a gun
in just or nunchuck in this case they
stood their ground man.
And these are,
these are brave kids.
I think there's a brave kids doing a
valuable public service.
That's my take from this right now.
And that's what the sticker is a pretty
innocent but strong way of being like,
fuck you.
And they also give every they to take it
off.
Don't goof off the only way.
But what I like about them,
if they don't immediately throw the
sticker on,
they say,
hey,
we're here to keep peace on the
sidewalk.
Can you please back up?
And if they do,
they don't fuck with their car.
So I think these guys have struck a good
balance of vigilante justice here.
Saying,
man,
that guy is so fun to drive.
His whole view was obstructed and he
continues to try to drive forward
getting more stickers.
So he continues to try to drive more and
they're putting more stickers on his
windshield and they're actually laying
on the front of the car.
They have.
This guy's having a fucked up day.
Oh,
there's someone else in the car.
Oh girl was wipes in the car.
Imagine being natural.
Yeah.
Wow.
This guy.
This is some shit.
He's getting out.
He's getting angry now.
Oh,
he punches now.
They're throwing punches.
Here we go.
Oh Man.
These vigilante.
Poke him out.
Let me help you up.
Well,
that's a humiliation.
Wow.
That was.
That was amazing.
The guy came out through applying,
now they've got this one huge ass like
you know in rocky,
they have like the super like USSR,
boxer.
They got one of these guys.
He's like the guy that confronts.
So this guy came out,
threw a punch and Ivan Drago,
Ivan Drago basically body dropped him
and then he's like,
here,
let me help you up to complete the
humiliation.
Wow.
This guy's days.
Fuck.
There's three stickers on it.
I wonder who's.
I wonder what the police say when they
come.
Oh,
here's what the sticker says.
It says,
I spit on everyone.
I drive where I want.
Stop a Douche bag.
That's what it says in Russian.
Hmm.
Wow.
That's amazing stuff,
man.
These kids are brave and they're doing a
valued publix.
That's a really cool.
Cool.
Thank you to Josh,
who by the way said you are by far my
favorite channel on Youtube.
So shout out to Josh.
I'm Matt Duncan's one that we.
Yeah,
I wasn't sure what.
That's all right.
I'm gonna.
Move on.
Matt says,
there was another bathroom habit I did
that I realized was normal seven years
ago.
I was talking to members of my tennis
team in my freshman year of college.
Whenever I used a Urinal or went pee,
I would always whip out my balls along
with my penis to peep.
I would pull the waistband under my
balls and that always felt more
comfortable and natural and when I
brought it up to my teammates,
I realized I was the only one that did
that among the team.
I was so embarrassed and I have since
changed my habits and I do not whip out
my balls anymore to pee,
but I miss it.
Is this normal?
Do you whip out your balls to p or just
your.
Your Rod as well?
I would love your thoughts.
Well,
Matt,
I'm so happy that you brought this to me
because I feel like here at the podcast
we're smashing taboos.
We are bringing things out to light that
people don't talk about and we are
normalizing behaviors that are normal
and good and just now before I get it,
now before I get into that,
all I want to say that we've converted a
lot of people.
A lot of people have been shamed to
wiping their ass from the back,
which is clownish.
It's ridiculous.
It's not convenient.
It's not as good.
A lot of people have taken the time at
home to sit and cut their balls and
pianists in their hand and to scoop
under while sitting comfortably with the
other hand and they found that that's a
superior method.
Now,
I'm not going to tell you right now that
the front way is superior even though
you have to be a fucking cave man to
stand up and squat and reach behind your
ass and wipe side decided to clean your
asshole.
I'm not going to tell you that.
I think once we pick out,
I'm just.
What I am saying is that I don't think
that US front wipers need to be
ostracized.
I don't think we need to be outcast and
demean because we approach problems
differently.
Now I come to this issue of whipping the
balls out.
Now,
this sweet young man,
Matt was,
he was,
um,
you know,
he was,
he was ridiculed by his teammates.
Well,
let me tell you,
Matt,
I always take my balls out fucking
proudly and you know why you take your
balls out and Matt,
because you're smart and you know what,
what makes sense?
Now if you just take your dick out,
you've got nothing to rest your pants
on.
Now you're probably like me.
You use a waste.
It works with the elastic waist.
If you're wearing an elastic waist pants
like I often do,
you put the waste under your balls
because if you just take your dick out,
you have to hold.
It looks ridiculous.
It's like a little tick tack peeking
over a fucking Mole Hill.
You need to take the balls out.
You got to let it all breathe and that's
an important thing and I personally find
it superior.
Now,
Matt,
don't let people tell you that you're
not that.
That's not the right way to do it
because that's just the absolute
outright disgusting criminal conspiracy.
Live to deep state line when I won't
stand for you.
Take your balls out along with your Dick
and now everyone is homes.
I'm like,
oh no,
I'm going to try that.
And then you're going to find out,
oh,
I like taking my balls out.
They'll do wrong with it.
It was all good guys backstage.
Do you take your balls out?
You know what it kind of depends on,
on.
It depends on what you're wearing.
It's situational highly situations and
the others,
if you're wearing jeans into the mic,
you really have no option if you wear
jeans shirt.
But if you're wearing like a,
like a basketball shorts than.
Yeah,
absolutely.
There you go.
You see that?
And Ian finally never.
Well in.
You don't have to strike that tone.
I'm trying to encourage young masculine.
Tone it down,
right?
Not that serious in his balls aren't
coming out.
Yeah,
they're not coming.
They're staying in there.
Thank you matt for the question and I
wish you all the best in life and all of
your bowl whipping out journeys.
And finally from cow.
First of all,
I want to say how much I love you guys
and everything that you do.
Well,
thank you very much.
Cow A cow.
I love you guys and everything that you
do.
Thank you [inaudible].
Love to hear that and that through you.
I found a ton of other creators and
content that I would never have all my
own.
That being said,
I want to see Ethan kind of a personal
question.
How are you capable of confirming and
admitting you were depressed?
Oh,
I want to answer this,
but I feel like it's an awful way to end
the show.
We were just having a good time with the
balls out.
We can do it next time.
Yeah,
I will say that for next time.
I do want to answer this.
He says I'll just finish.
Currently,
I'm sort of a social stigma at my
university that depression is a choice
and a sign of weakness and I know that
I'm definitely not happy.
How do you detect this and how are you
dealing with it currently if you don't
feel comfortable answering?
Well I do.
I'll answer it.
I think I can answer it without being
like super depressing.
I agree.
When I was in college there was a really
big stigma about being depressed and I'm
sure I was depressed at the time and I
think it's really well.
I think it's changed,
but it's really fucked up because I
remember at my college dorm there was a
sign
on the wall with like Prozac and it was
some kind of insinuation that like,
um,
if you take it your week or something or
not,
that was the subtext because it was
really like a how fucked up is society
that everybody's taking Prozac.
Right.
And then sinuation is like,
oh,
you don't need that shit.
I wasn't on anything like that.
But um,
I agreed.
I saw that and I was like,
Oh yeah,
everyone's on drugs,
you know?
Um,
the idea of treating depression was
something like a.
yeah,
it was very stigma.
It was like,
like I said in the uptivity,
it's not sexy to be depressed.
It's like it's pathetic.
Just sounds pathetic.
Like there's two kinds of price.
They're like everyone is depressed and
then there's like the real,
the real depressed in his treatment.
And maybe people just like combine it.
The people who.
Yeah,
well the people who,
everyone gets depressed sometimes,
but people who get depressed sometimes
don't understand what it's like to be
depressed for two years.
So that's why I think there was a
disconnect there.
It's just,
it's a,
it's just a disconnect.
It's a misunderstanding.
But be that as it may,
you know,
I think I've been depressed for a really
long time and I remember I always,
I always knew that I had really severe
anxiety.
I mean I was diagnosed with generalized
anxiety disorder when I went off to
college and it was like really crippling
all throughout college.
And I had accepted that I had a problem.
But I remember the first time when we
were living in Israel,
I saw a psychiatrist.
Okay.
Um,
because of my anxiety was really bad,
or maybe I was,
I was having some kind of weird thing
and I just wanted to talk to a therapist
and he had said,
I told him,
yeah,
it was a therapist and I was talking
about my symptoms and I was like,
you know,
I'm anxious and I,
there's this one thing that I get all
the time that I still get,
which is that I get like foggy brain and
I feel like not myself.
I feel like I'm having a bad high.
And um,
I really hate that feeling.
So awful.
And then the therapist was like,
oh,
so,
um,
it sounds like you have depression.
And that shocked me.
I was almost offended.
I was like,
I don't.
I'm like,
I have anxiety,
not depression.
I was actually genuinely defensive and I
was like,
what?
Like fuck,
like fuck you,
I don't have,
I'm,
I have anxiety.
And my reaction was very much like,
like,
fuck you dude.
And uh,
that was like,
that must've been like seven years ago
probably.
It was when we were living in Ramat Gan
gun and I've never treated it or
anything like,
um,
but
I've been like desperate enough where I
was like,
oh,
I need some fucking help.
And so that's why I want to talk to that
guy and I'm,
yeah,
I just remember being really defensive
and uh,
that's.
And that,
that was so long ago and now it's come
to the point where I've slowly kind of
realized that like my anxiety has given
away at that.
It's morphed into something else.
Like in college,
my anxiety was just this crippling a,
I don't know.
Well,
it's free.
It's frequent that anxiety and
depression go hand in hand,
you know?
And so yeah,
the more I thought about it and the more
time I had to accept that,
I realized that it was probably at this
point more depression than there is
anxiety.
It's kind of like I addressed the
anxiety because I accepted that that's
what I had.
And so,
but the depression,
I was so,
I didn't want to have it so bad that I
ignored it and never addressed it.
And so now I feel like I'm,
now I'm really accepting it after
looking back and thinking how I feel.
I mean,
look at the,
um,
just read the symptoms,
man.
For me it's like,
yes,
yes.
Like,
let me read this off.
Like if I go there now,
but it's like,
you know,
I'm here.
Let me see.
This shit was like fucking 100 percent.
Yes.
I'm just trying to find this list of uh,
symptoms come up for fuck sake.
Um,
let's see.
Some signs you might have depression,
sad,
empty,
anxious,
helpless,
worthless or guilty or hopeless,
irritable,
less interested in activities,
less energetic.
Trouble concentrating,
changes in the way you sleep.
I sleep great.
That's it.
Everything else though,
changes in appetite.
I'm always hungry.
Aches and pains.
Not really actually,
but everything else.
Like I'm sad,
empty,
anxious.
Always helpless,
worthless,
guilty.
Always.
Like I got to the point now where I was
like,
I'm really now decided to like actually
treat this because it's become
unbearable for me recently is that I
was,
I'm like always at war with myself and
my head,
like torturing myself.
Like every little thing,
like social things pass things,
things that happen.
A long time ago things had happened now
on day to day basis,
small things like you'll say something
and then you're like torture or I'll do
something.
Anything,
but it's like I'm always feeling guilty
or is it just like the dumbest things
like and you know,
that,
but just always at war with myself in my
head.
Hopeless,
pessimistic,
you know?
Yeah.
Irritable,
big time.
Fucking so irritable and I hate being
irritable because you know,
like,
you know that you have,
you shouldn't be but you are as the
worst and you just can't help it.
You just like fuck that.
Everything annoys me but.
And I don't and I so don't want to be an
asshole.
I so don't want to be an asshole right
now,
but I'm just so irritated.
I hate that and I would feel that all
the time,
like
all the time everyday.
So in bowl and it's exhausting for you
because I'm fucking not that pleasant to
be around most of the time.
Loss of interest in activities.
I don't have hobbies.
I don't enjoy doing anything.
I used to love playing video games and
for the past years like I don't,
I didn't even listen to music.
I don't even enjoy listening to music.
Less energetic.
Yeah.
Tired all the time.
Trouble concentrating.
So hard for me to do shit.
Trouble remembering details.
Isla to have trouble remembering
details.
Zip Code.
Oh yes.
Oh my God.
Oh,
that will drive me crazy.
Ethan doesn't know the address of his
home.
Well,
I do.
Just not.
There's no you don't.
I do.
Just not the zip.
Well that's like half of the address.
What else do I need to know?
I don't understand why people ask for
zip codes anymore.
Here's the fucking address.
Here's the city.
You don't need this navy.
I'm irritable too,
but oh my God.
Every time you think.
Well,
last zip code.
It's like it's your home insurance.
I don't know.
Remember zip codes.
I'm overwhelmed to make decisions
whether big or small.
Unmanned man.
It was like just.
I mean I was at the point recently where
it was like,
I cannot continue to live my life like
this.
I will do anything.
And you guys might recall me saying that
I had like this bottle of
antidepressants by my bed for the
longest time because I felt like I
hadn't tried everything first and I feel
like I took three months and I actually
did make a lot of positive changes in my
life,
but I still felt awful,
I guess not.
I,
I made a pretty good at.
For me the biggest,
the biggest thing for me was like
getting away from social media,
from Youtube and it.
But it's hard to know sometimes it's
like leaving youtube sometimes makes you
more anxious
and then everyone else gets upset and
that makes you more anxious.
And so it's hard.
It's hard to know what is the right
thing for you or whatever.
But anyway,
I don't know,
I've never gone to therapy there.
I have my first therapy appointment on
Monday.
Pretty excited.
I'm going,
if he's going to fix me,
right?
Uh,
I'll be like,
alright,
you know,
I,
I went to a therapist once through a
kaiser,
which is our healthcare.
And it was such an awful experience.
I never wanted to go again.
I show up.
It's like Mcdonald's therapy I show up
and right out the bat,
you know,
you expect that.
It's always like,
tell me about your family.
Where did you grow up?
Like,
get to know the guy,
get comfortable.
So I sit down and I swear to God,
this is what he does.
He goes,
all right,
so what's wrong?
But what do you want to talk about?
Like,
what's bothering you?
What's wrong?
I was like,
Whoa,
like fucking go to treat a girl to
dinner before you fucker.
You know,
I was just blown away by that.
He's like,
what's bothering you?
We have 30 minutes.
Come on.
We've got plenty of.
I got a lot of patients here.
It was fucking crazy.
I felt so uncomfortable do the whole
thing because I don't know this guy.
So I was like,
oh well we've got a bunch of ads on my
youtube channel that I don't want to do
and I don't feel like making content,
but I have these obligations.
Then he's like,
so tell me,
uh,
how did.
So how do you make money on youtube
again?
Was fucking awful.
I love that.
That's like a great name.
So tell me what's bothering you,
what's on your mind?
Well,
uh,
my father,
raped me when I was a kid and uh,
all right,
well here's what you do.
Just forget all about that crazy.
So I'm going to a private therapists
that came highly recommended from a
friend.
I'm really excited to Beverly Hills,
but you know,
he's fucking legit.
Uh,
yeah.
but to answer your original question,
took a bit of a tangent here.
Your original question was,
how did you confirm and admit you were
depressed?
Well,
for me it took me a long time,
um,
because I was embarrassed and ashamed
and I felt like people around it's kind
of embarrassing thing to,
Oh,
I'm depressed.
oh,
get over it.
I got an email.
People just don't understand.
I got an email from someone that like A.
Anyway,
whatever people don't understand.
But,
uh,
to you,
I would just ask yourself,
I mean,
you clearly are aware that something's
off and you're not happy.
There's clearly some aspects of your
life that are you're not happy with and
you're not comfortable with that you
would like to change.
They're causing you to feel possibly
depressed.
I would,
I would consider looking at these
symptoms because for me it's really just
been crippling and a large part of the
reason why we've just been gone for so
long.
But also I'm not a professional.
I can't diagnose you,
so you should.
You should see a therapist.
I feel like everyone.
I know it seems like a luxury,
but actually a friend of ours was
telling us like,
there's,
there's cheap.
What was the name of this place?
She said,
well,
they have therapy on a sliding scale,
so if you're broke you can go see a
therapist for 20 bucks.
[inaudible]
and also there's,
there's,
you know,
there's ways to figure it out.
But ultimately I think it's important
for people to know that you just,
you don't have to suffer,
you don't have to carry it.
You got to make the decision that you're
just going to fight it.
Right?
You don't want to be a victim to sell.
Fuck you.
No,
fuck that.
It's like you're just wasting your time
on this earth to feeling miserable and
what's the point of that?
So do what you can,
you know,
because there's a lot of people before
you that have dealt with it and gotten
out of the woods and they're really
smart and they are there to help
everybody else because it sucks there to
help you with therapy because they're
geniuses.
These therapists,
they have studied,
they have phds.
They have studied this shit for decades.
They know how the brain works,
right?
That's,
that's something.
I'm just a guy.
I don't know how the brain works.
Right,
but they can get in your head and
untangle shit and understand you and
ways that you can't.
They've got drugs that help ease the
burden while you figure it out.
Yeah.
No,
you don't have to be miserable all.
Well,
if you already are miserable,
what do you have to lose anyway?
Because a fuck.
It's like at one at,
at a certain point,
nothing else matters,
but getting better because what does it.
What does anything matter?
If you're that miserable,
it's just like what else?
At that point matters at all except
prioritizing number one yourself and
getting better.
You can't help anyone around.
You can't do
anything for yourself or anyone else
until you feel better.
So that's my,
that's my opinion.
Yeah.
Um,
and depressions on the rise,
you know,
more people are feeling it more than
ever because my theory personally on
that is that the world is increasingly
complex,
complicated,
difficult to find your place in the
world,
the find a spouse in the world to find a
career,
to find a purpose,
to make money.
Everything is so hard to figure out
that.
Um,
and we carry a lot of stress and
alongside a lot of bills,
a lot of responsibility
generation especially like who can
afford it.
No fucking body.
Like I think about our situation.
We are fortunate enough to have been
able to buy a house.
But,
but I know the feeling from you just a
few years ago did we?
No,
no,
we,
we've worked all our life and we weren't
even close.
We have,
we were on.
We were statistically anomalous with our
success and the amount of money that we
were able to make in the short time from
being successful.
But we've been,
like you said,
just a couple short years earlier,
making like 30,
$40,000
with you and the two of us.
And um,
that's important.
Yeah.
You're like,
buy a house.
Never happened.
So I wonder when we're in this
anomalous,
like an unbelievably lucky situation.
How the fuck does anyone else have a
chance?
But it doesn't.
But again,
that you can be at any station of life
and still life is complicated in this
day and age with the Internet,
with the cars,
with bill's responsibility and know I'm
more depressed now because I feel more
lost in my purpose.
And like,
I actually heard a really good.
I don't remember who said it,
but it's like,
um,
when you have money and like financial
safety,
all that's left is in your head.
That was talking to about not when I.
Cause I was saying before that you're
always like,
well,
if only I could afford that trip,
I wouldn't be happy.
But until then I can afford it,
or if I just or,
or it's like if only I could afford this
house,
that would be perfect.
My thing was like,
Oh,
if only I couldn't,
didn't pay rent,
rent.
I'd be set for life.
So you always have this like you're
chasing a goal.
If I then I'll be happy.
Right now I'm not happy because I can't
afford it.
But you work towards it and it gives you
a purpose.
Yeah.
But when you can afford it and you're
still not happy,
then it's like,
what is that thing that will make me
happy?
Yeah.
But I.
But anyway,
I'm in,
I'm in a rare situation.
It's hard to relate to what I'm going
through there.
But just generally speaking,
life is so complicated.
Like think back 50 years,
people didn't have phones that have
fucking Internet,
they just worked on farms.
I genuinely think that like if you just
woke up at 8:00
AM and worked on the farm for eight
hours and went home and ate dinner and
chill,
it's like that simple man.
There's nothing to crave.
Like that's,
you know,
that's.
And I think that like modern day life
really goes against our,
are a fundamental instincts as animals,
like billions of years of,
of,
uh,
end stinks and expectation of what life
is and how to survive.
That's what it is,
right?
Billions of years of survival instincts
have all of the sudden in the past 100
years completely betrayed us because all
of a sudden these survival instincts
that we've inherited over evolution,
billions of years are no longer relevant
at all.
Right?
And that's fucked up.
So I think a lot of people have,
have trouble adjusting.
It's weird because also you all of a
sudden,
I didn't have a lot of opportunities.
The demon before.
You have a lot of,
you know,
there's a lot of good that came with it.
Sure.
But it's also great playing.
Yeah.
So,
you know,
I think,
I think that,
um,
I think it's important to bear that in
mind that life is really fucking can be
very challenging and confusing and
overwhelming.
It's like my God who can balance all
those things when instinctually I just
want to go plant some carrots,
right?
Or go gather some berries or some shit
or go kill a deer and then chill and the
TP,
you know.
So anyway,
I'm looking forward to the essays of
disproving my theory.
Well,
that's just my thoughts and if you
disagree,
you're wrong.
Anyway.
I hope I wish you all the best.
And um,
and uh,
yeah,
you should dump.
Don't be afraid to seek help and don't
feel weak because you are not alone.
And increasingly less alone.
You know,
100 years ago was like,
or maybe 200,000
years ago,
you know,
if I've heard this and I don't know if
it's true,
but I've heard this,
that like an amish communities that
depression and anxiety is like
completely nonexistent.
Hmm.
No,
you know about the amish.
The Amish.
Yeah.
And that,
that makes sense to me,
right?
Because they're fully fulfilled.
They have very basic,
uh,
or not basic,
but they have very,
they know what to expect every day and
they're fulfilled every day and their
life is,
they understand what it is day to day.
It's not like you went about how many
days do you wake up and you're like,
like,
fuck,
what,
what?
Like what am I going to do today?
Like,
you know,
anyway,
that's it.
Meanwhile,
Papa's in the backyard.
And uh,
clothes on the hanging pent on the rack,
flapping in the wind.
Papa clutches his heart play the music.
Papa clutches his heart
is running around the backyard,
playing with a paper airplane.
And Papa clutches his heart.
I feel mad with no,
no pizza sauce.
Remember me bury me in my favorite
mayor,
narrow,
very narrow,
and my favorite pizza,
the meat lovers,
pizza with sausage and Pepperoni.
And remember,
made fun and make my tombstone a giant
box of Papa John's with my pitcher.
Proudly the box before they removed it
with an apostrophe.
John's my company and I bumped John.
Shanda.
Thank you everyone for watching and
remember,
better ingredients,
better butter sauce.
Never disrespect to Alfredo sauce and to
you,
I see this.
Oh No,
no.
Falls over and has a heart attack and
dies.
Guys,
that is the show.
Thank you for watching.
H three podcast revolution.
I've just been birth.
The new title for this show experience
is no longer adequate.
It is a revolution.
I hope that,
uh,
you know what?
It's the h three podcast a.
what's the phrase?
The paradigm shift?
The h three paradigm shift revolution.
I hope your day has been shifted and a
paradigm and we will see you on Friday.
As always,
next week.
This is your papa and chief,
Ethan,
Papa,
John Shatner.
I'll be saying to you papa's blessings
and have happy weekend to all my little
pizza boys.
All my dope boys,
all my little bows out there,
all my little pizza.
I eat meat eater,
loving or not.
I just remember me.
Good night.
And God bless you.
Can.